it started I only remember the date
because it was my birthday night March
19th he started feeling not really great
we were eating dinner
he was like I'm just not feeling very
good and then for the next six days he
basically laid in bed and slept all day
and that was his only symptom that's
just fatigue so we had extreme fatigue
it sounds like extreme fatigue could not
get out of bed and I would try to get
him out to eat something but it was very
he didn't really have an appetite and it
was just fatigue and then on the morning
of March 26 I asked him to change our
son's diaper and I heard a loud sound
and hit fainted and I said okay that's
it before had he ever fainted before oh
no can't never fainted before so it
really scared him and I you know I got
scared just because I don't know
fainting always makes me scared so I
said that's it I said let's go to the
urgent care so we went to one of them
the one that was open we're either of
you thinking that maybe this is covin at
that time well I mean not really to be
honest he didn't have a fever he didn't
have a cough he still had a sense of
smell and a small sense of appetite and
if he coughed it was very Fleming it
wasn't dry and he was coughing up phlegm
so we just didn't think we didn't think
that it was Kovac yet it was weird that
he was sick at the time when this was
all happening you know so we took him to
the urgent care and a couple hours later
he came out get a chest x-ray he said
they said it's pneumonia they don't
think it's Kovac because I don't have
any of the COBIT symptoms so they didn't
even get me a Kovac test so that must
have given you a small sense of relief
Amanda just to hear okay I don't have
Kovac yes let's get the medication and
let's go home go ahead yes yes in fact
we were both staying in the car this is
the only time
you're kind of like oh it's pneumonia we
went to pick up his medications he went
straight back to bed and for the next
three days he was on these medications
and Gailey just kept getting worse yeah
back up just a second Amanda because
what does getting worst mean oh um so he
was having the chills
no fever though but having chills and
his breathing it was on and off not
regular but anytime I would ask him to
come to the table or even lying in bed
he would have these spells where his
breathing was really heavy and fast and
it's like he couldn't catch his breath
it took him an hour to to get out of bed
to sit up to get out of bed to to walk
to the table that took an hour Wow
did it deteriorate very quickly then
over the weekend from what hurts'
bribing yes so we called a friend of
ours who's a doctor at cedars-sinai and
he said go to the emergency room now and
so we did on Monday morning March 30th
we drove to the emergency room and and I
dropped him off and this is one of the
saddest parts I you know we thought I
would see him in two hours you know I
just I said I'm gonna take Elvis for a
walk and you know call me when you want
me to come pick you up I mean we weren't
I don't know just weren't thinking and
so I didn't even give him a kiss or a
hug because we were also kind of self
isolating from him because you know we
had this ten month old baby and got a
call from Nick in about an hour and he
said a man they admitted me I am now in
a bed with oxygen and I said oh okay
he said bill knows some things in a
couple hours at home and I'll call you
in a couple hours were you worried so
that point Amanda or were you still
thinking okay it's still okay I was
getting a little worried I was getting a
little worried at this point
yes nick has never been hospitalized he
is not he has no pre
to see conditions and at 1:30 in the
morning he called me he said honey
they're taking me to the ICU I'm not
getting enough oxygen to my organs
Amanda it was the next morning at 4 a.m.
he called me and he said honey they want
to put me on a ventilator again we were
just talking over the phone we facetimed
quickly it was 4:00 a.m. though it
happened so quickly
and and he's saying they want to
incubate me right away and so I again I
love you um oh my gosh okay
and um you know and he did say he's a
I'm a little scared he said I'm a little
scared and that must have scared you to
hear him say that he was scared oh it's
terrifying for some reason just seems
scarier just when you said he called you
at 4:00 a.m. you know the phone rings at
4:00 a.m. and we all sort of freeze and
to be honest Gail I didn't even really
understand what all of this meant in the
meantime they said we want to start some
of the kovat medicines
it won't hurt him if he's still negative
if he's positive we're gonna get a leg
up on wrist
what were the medicines Amanda they
wanted to do hydroxychloroquine and the
z-pak basically yeah yes so they did
they started those medicines they did
the deep kovin chest scrape and it came
back positive do you think that
combination really gave him an advantage
I do I do think it helped because Nick
was on a steady incline of getting
better they also started in him on they
asked me about REM des mere clinical
trial so I couldn't firmed with a friend
of mine again who was a doctor he said
definitely do this clinical trial if
Nick gets the drug there's been a lot of
benefits to it so we said yes to that
and he went on his clinical trial I will
never know if he got from des of me or
not the doctors won't don't even know
however so he went on that as well he
started to get better
and we were we had plans to take him off
the ventilator and things were really
moving this was like day 6 into
incubation things were moving in a
really positive light they did the thing
where they laid him on his belly which
is what doctors are doing now that was
breathing yes yes and that really helped
Gail that when they did that they had
him on his belly I think for 16 hours
and that really really helped him get
better it really helped him be able to
breathe so we were all on a very
positive ok he's fighting this he's
beating this or your posts and it was so
exciting yes your pose we think again
he's turned a corner yes yes yes oh he
turned a corner and then I get a phone
call that he got an infection and the
infection caused a huge fever to spike
which caused his blood pressure to drop
his pulse gone for 2 minutes and they
had to resuscitate his heart and that's
when I I really kind of lost it for the
first time and you know it was really
really really scary um talk about a
rollercoaster Amanda yes who steps
forward and then a step back yes I was
because we were on it was literally we
the call about morning was supposed to
be we're taking him off the ventilator
today because he's doing so well and
then that morning's phone call was the
exact opposite
the kovat was on its way out this was a
new infection that came in and that
literally just took him out they said
Amanda we are trying to get him onto an
ECMO machine as soon as possible this
will save his life what is for an ECMO
machine it basically takes over the
functions of your heart and lungs to run
your heart lungs outside of your body
until your body becomes strong enough to
run your run the heart lungs alone the
doctors were like this will help us this
will give us time
and this will save his life so the ECMO
machine is tubes that they enter through
the groin into the heart and lungs one
of these can you all tubes was
restricting blood flow to Nick's right
leg and this can happen it is a common
side effect that the ECMO machine in
saving your life can kind of disrupt
blood flow so it could cause a blood
clot then yes they called me one day and
they just said Amanda unfortunately the
leg now is the body is trying to save
this leg but it's fighting it and in
return and could cause a lot of damage
to the body to put it simply it sounds
like you had to make a decision between
saving his leg or saving his life you
know Gil yes he's a dancer he's an actor
he's a performer it was not an easy
decision to make
however when I explained to him that it
was a situation of life her leg I know
Nick will have said you get rid of my
leg so that's how I kind of made the
decision Amanda you are so inspiring to
so many people your optimism is so
infectious and because you believe you
give us all reason to believe I believe
because Gail I have a positive person
I'm a glass-half-full kind of gal one of
Nick's main doctors said to me from day
one and I love him for this he said
Amanda we're gonna look at this in a
positive light because the minute we
look at it in any other light there's no
options and I just truly believe that
Nick has that this is a story I have
gathered now an army that that are
praying for him that are singing his
song every day I feel like there is an
army of people behind him behind us that
are waiting to hear these this good news
and I just believe I get chosen
I just believe that he will wake up and
share with us this story I'm telling my
side on this end and I I can't wait to
hear what you situs I like when you said
you've got an army because there you've
started the social media movement wake
up Nick hashtag wake up Nick I didn't
even plan on it
you know this way and then as everything
started unfolding I started feeling very
helpless because you know right now I
can't be by his side I can't be holding
his hand and so I just started this
because I thought you know Nick would
love this what would you love about this
when he hears that everyone is playing
his song every day 3 or 6 p.m. or
wherever you are in the world and
singing his lyrics and cheering him on
and praying for him and now it's on the
radio game yeah he won't believe it and
I had no intention of this happening but
it all just started happening you talked
to Nick on an iPad were you able to do
that or you have had no conversation
since you had yet they allowed me to
speak to him from an iPad and then a
friend of ours gave us this awesome
walkie-talkie so I can send him messages
anything throughout the day I can just
say hi Nick I love you I'm here does the
man so what are you gonna do now for the
rest of the day cuz I would imagine you
don't go to the hospital do you I go to
the hospital every day I stand outside
of Cedars my play next song and I cheer
him on from outside of Cedar sinai every
day and their day a woman to find she
rolled her window down and she goes I'm
praying for you he's gonna wake up wake
up Nick and I just I got chills cuz I
just you know again is that support but
is just coming from all angles that you
don't even know I just feel so positive
after listening to you mean it's song
live your life you've got your plans
I've got mine who understands how
stars align if one shooting past and
I'll consider a sign that you are still
alive I know he wrote these horrors like
years ago but they're just so I mean I
just think this song it's um it's just
so it just resonates with what
everyone's going through at this time
you know just to live your life and and
just be so grateful for it you know